[Musica]
alzi la mano chi di voi in questa sala
ha già figli circa la metà e ora alzi la
mano chi di voi in questa sala non ha
figli può più della metà e ora alzi la
mano chi in questa sala non può avere
figli
sei in italia il 20 per cento della
popolazione è sterile non può avere
figli e deve ricorre a tecniche di
fecondazione assistita in questa sala
siamo 500 il che vuol dire che cento di
noi hanno problemi a concepire allora
due sono le cose o qui a fiorano
modenese tutti avete fatto i test per la
fertilità e sapete che potete avere
figli oppure qui a fiorano modenese come
ovunque la gente su quest'argomento
mente mente perché prova per prova
vergogna imbarazzo oggi vi vorrei
parlare del pregiudizio sterilità uguale
vergogna e di alcune cose importanti che
dovete sapere sulla fertilità vi
chiederei una cortesia
vorrei non utilizzare più il termine
sterile perché è veramente sterile
pertanto vi chiederei come non si dice
più handicappato ma si dice disabile o
diversamente abile vi chiederei di
utilizzare da ora il termine
diversamente fertile
guardate sapete quando ho scoperto che
esisteva questo pregiudizio sterilità
uguale vergogna ho scoperto molto
giovane quattro anni ed ero la terza di
cinque figli due genitori medico quindi
sempre molto impegnati
noi siamo cresciuti con questa donna lei
è maria la nostra tata dolce bella
sorridente divertente ma in alcuni
momenti mai davanti a noi ma io spiavo
aveva dei momenti di sconforto
profondissimo e piangeva tra le
ginocchia di mia nonna perché non poteva
avere figli con suo marito vincenzo e
diceva il medico mi ha detto che i miei
spermatozoi uccidono gli spermatozoi di
mio marito e poi diceva io mi vergogno a
tornare al paese
lei era di salcito un paese piccolissimo
del molise perché tutti sanno che non
possa avere figli lei si vergognava
tornano nel paese io la sentivo non
capivo bene che cosa volesse dire ma non
lo capiva bene neanche lei
e siccome l'amavo tantissimo mi chiudeva
in bagno a piangere finché a un certo
punto quando avevo quasi nove anni era
l'undici gennaio del 1983 uscì la
notizia sui giornali e sui telegiornali
che nacque la prima bambina in provetta
in italia era nata la prima bambina in
provetta e io mi immaginavo questo avevo
nove anni ma avevo capito che per me per
maria si poteva fare qualcosa e per me
era importante in quel momento ho deciso
che il mio modello di vita sarebbero
stati i miei genitori e il mio modello
di paziente sarebbe stata maria
e oggi maria che purtroppo non c'è più
sarebbe diversamente fertile e verrebbe
da me che sono diventata medico e che in
questo momento faccio incontrare i
gameti della donna che sono già cuciti
con i gameti dell'uomo che sono gli
spermatozoi facilito il loro incontro
facilito il loro rapporto in vitro sotto
una cappa con un microscopio genero
questi embrione di cui il 35 per cento
diventerà un individuo messo dentro la
pancia della mamma
tutti noi siamo il prodotto di un
embrione questo lavoro l'ho amato
tantissimo lo porta davanti fin dai
primi studi ho lottato contro i
pregiudizi come sto facendo adesso ho
studiato sono diventata ricercatrice
sono diventata docente sempre con questo
argomento e adesso ho aperto e dirigo un
centro di procreazione assistita nel
lazio un centro pubblico che è il più
importante del centro e sud italia
perché attivato il servizio e di
fecondazione eterologa
vi dirò dopo che cos'è la fecondazione
eterologa per ora voglio dirvi che cosa
insegnato a me questo lavoro mi ha
insegnato che la vergogna deve
abbandonare per primo il medico perché
questo perché il paziente che vede la
tua vulnerabilità entra in empatia
bisogna abbracciare l'eccellenza e la
debolezza che è in noi e questo è la
base della fiducia
vi faccio un esempio e vi riporto due
esperienze personali viene una paziente
mi dice dottoressa ho avuto una
gravidanza extra uterina e mi hanno
dovuto togliere una tuba e io le dico
posso dirti una cosa ma che rimanga fra
noi ce l'ho avuto anche una gravidanza
extra uterina
so che cosa provi so il dolore
fisico e psicologico che ti provoca
questo ma ti posso garantire che
possiamo superarla insieme io al suo
segreto e lei al mio segreto vi faccio
un altro esempio sempre personale
dottoressa ho letto e so che con queste
tecniche possono aumentare le
malformazioni del bambino devo dirti una
cosa che rimanga fra noi però mia figlia
che non è nata da tecniche di
fecondazione assistita è nato con una
malformazione la sua mano destra aveva
un dito in più è nata con sei dita per
me è stato veramente una doccia fredda e
tutto il primo anno della sua vita
ho passato a cercare di risolvere questo
problema l'ho portata dai migliori
specialisti alla fine l'ho fatto operare
e la sua mano destra è diventata
perfetta
volete sapere è mancina questo cosa vuol
dire gli spiego che mia figlia ora è
grande e bella
bolt e brilliant quindi anche questo si
può superare ritorno sull'argomento vi
ho lasciato prima che la fecondazione
eterologa
abbiamo capito cosa sono i gameti
maschili e femminili e che devono
incontrarsi per dare un embrione che
andranno in lutero della mamma e li
diventerà un individuo ma ci sono alcune
situazioni in cui purtroppo uno o
entrambi i partner non hanno più questi
gameti
le motivazioni sono tante una menopausa
precoce un tumore
il lavoro un trauma
lasciamo stare l'importante è questo
devono ricorrere a donatori esterni di
gameti che li donano lido nino per
fecondare con quelli del partner e
questa è la massima espressione di
vergogna perché
perché tra marito e moglie la compagnia
compagna si inserisce il terzo incomodo
l'amante segreta che unirà i suoi gameti
a quello del partner ma io vi dico se
qualcuno di voi avesse bisogno di un
trapianto d'organo cuore un rene
qualcosa per sopravvivere
questa donazione o questo donatore lo
vedrebbe come una vergogna come una
sconfitta o come un'opportunità ve lo
dico io
la vedrebbe come un'opportunità e
ringrazierebbe dio di avergli trovato
una di aver trovato una donatrice un
donatore per quell organo sapete che
dicono i miei pazienti quando mi rendo
conto che con i loro gameti non c'è più
niente da fare
gli parlo della fecondazione eterologa
due cose mi dico la prima è questa se
l'aereo sta precipitando
eto'o è il paracadute che fai ti butti
ovviamente di bucchi e poi gli dico
un'altra cosa che mi entusiasma e mi
appassiona
questa è l'unica terapia in medicina
esistente che ti riporta indietro nel
tempo
io lo definisco il santo graal della
medicina
niente così nessuna terapia nessun
trattamento
ma genera tantissimi dubbi
e allora cerchiamo di eliminarli questi
dubbi di smantellarli lo faccio con le
domande che loro mi fanno allora mi
dicono dottoressa ma questo bambino avrà
i miei geni
no ovviamente non avrà i suoi geni
perché geni sono quelli della donatrice
del donatore ma non esiste solo la
genetica ognuno di noi possiede un elica
di dna che questa che voi vedete
lunghissima di cui attivato soltanto il
7 per cento
e questa attivazione del 7 per cento
dipende da quello che tu mangi da quello
che respiri da quanto sport fai 66
stressato se vive in un ambiente
inquinato e lo stesso embrione dentro di
te ho dentro di me sarebbe diverso
un'altra domanda che mi fanno sempre
dottoressa ma mi somiglierà e allora li
introduco la tecnologia e gli dico
guarda esistono delle applicazioni
collegate a queste banche tutti fai un
self mandi il self analizzano 1000 punti
del tuo volto e trovano un donatore una
donatrice che ti somiglia il più
possibile ognuno di noi ha sette sosia
lo troveranno è ma così mi vedono ben
utilizziamo in un'altra c'è un'app che
ti dice a quale i vip assomigli
assomiglia giu la roberts ti mandiamo la
foto di giulia roberts e troviamo la
donatrice che somiglia a te mi dicono
dottoressa mi ha detto che la
percentuale non è del 100 per cento
e allora lei come fa a sapere qual è
l'embrione che diventerà un individuo
messo dentro di me io gli dico ormai non
lo decido più io abbiamo studiato
abbiamo visto che cosa rende l'embrione
migliore abbiamo inserito queste nozioni
dentro uno strumento che ha generato un
algoritmo matematico
o che ci dice qual è l'embrione che ha
avuto più che avra piu probabilita di
diventare un individuo è ma io ho paura
che vengano scambiati gameti questo il
terrore di tutti enrico stai tranquilla
esiste un sistema che noi abbiamo che
funziona come se fossi un ladro a un
anti taccheggio come il ladro quando
scappa suona tutto noi sbagliamo
provetta e qui sono tutto il laboratorio
e in questo modo sono riuscita piano
piano a scardinare i loro dubbi
adesso però vorrei concludere con 3
punti e poi vi lascio il primo punto il
mio messaggio forte che vorrei che
recepisce è questo fate i figli
fateli presto fateli essendo informati
di quello potete andare incontro
e se dovete ricorrere al medico e alle
tecniche di fecondazione artificiale non
lo vedete come una vergogna o una
sconfitta ma come un'opportunità ma
questo non è possibile
seconda cosa lo volete sapere quando ho
deciso di venire al the licks di modena
lo ha deciso quando è uscito una canzone
di questo cantante lui e j ax e la
scorsa estate a luglio mi sembra uscita
la canzone si chiama tutto su mia madre
questa canzone grida al mondo la sua
sofferenza la difficoltà che ha avuto
nel rapporto con sua moglie perché non
riuscivano avere figli usa è
un'espressione che mi ha colpito
tantissimo
sono caduto con le ginocchia a terra è
proprio questa la sensazione che si
prova e poi ringrazia tutti noi che
abbiamo pagato i biglietti del suo
concerto con cui lui ha potuto pagare i
medici per realizzare questo miracolo
ho capito che il mio messaggio poteva
passare perché lui ha portato quello che
sto dicendo io
diversamente fertile senza vergogna
tecniche di fecondazione assistita
opportunità e adesso concludo
definitivamente vorrei creare una
breccia sul muro della vergogna
chiedendovi chi di voi è diversamente
fertile ma non lo farò ma vi voglio
chiedere un'altra cosa
chi di voi porterà il messaggio di
questo switch a una persona diversamente
fertile grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]